rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de la zététique
si vous ne savez pas ce qu'elle avait
dit qu'il est possible que ce mot vous
paraisse un peu bizarre mais si je vous
dis qu'en anglais zététique se dit
scepticisme c'est ici donc ça vous
paraîtra déjà moins étrange
la zététique c'est une discipline
inventée par Henry Broch dans les années
80 et la définition qu'il en donne est
assez simple la zététique c'est l'art du
doute
l'art de ne pas accepter comme vrai tout
ce qui est affirmé comme vrai et par art
il faut entendre technique méthode
la zététique c'est une méthode mais
c'est aussi et peut-être même encore
plus fondamentalement une attitude une
attitude intellectuelle d'examen
critique les discours et des croyances
initialement la zététique a été fondée
dont le but d'étudier scientifiquement
les phénomènes paranormaux et quand je
dis étudier scientifiquement les
phénomènes paranormaux faut être bien
clair ça veut dire montrer par les
outils de la science que ces phénomènes
dit par un ormeau n'en sont pas
montrez qu'il existe des explications
rationnelles à ces phénomènes et que
donc il n'y a pas besoin d'invoquer des
causes surnaturelles parce que invoquer
des explications surnaturelles à la
limite pourquoi pas mais pas avant
d'avoir épuisé toutes les explications
qui entrent dans le cadre de ce qu'on
connaît déjà
donc la zététique c'est l'application de
la méthode scientifique au phénomène
paranormaux et au pseudo-sciences dans
le but de ne pas se laisser tromper par
des discours frauduleux par des discours
prétendument scientifiques et par
extension de développer son esprit
critique face aux croyances de tous les
jours
alors on va voir beaucoup de choses à
dire mais avant ça je voudrais citer
deux livres sur lesquels on va s'appuyer
aujourd'hui de livres du fondateur de la
zététique Henry Broque donc je précise
que ce sont des livres grand public très
courts très accessibles l'art du doute
sous-titrée commence à franchir du
prêt-à-penser et comment des jouer les
pièges de l'information
sous-titrés les règles d'or de la
zététique
ces deux livres ont été publiés en 2008
et ce sont deux livres complémentaires
puisque l'art du doute va plutôt parler
des principes de la zététique de la
vision générale
tandis que les règles d'or de la
zététique va davantage porter sur la
mise en application de ces principes
alors d'abord Henry Broque nous rappelle
que le mot zététique n'est pas du tout
nouveau puisqu'on le trouve dès 1694
chez Corneille dans son dictionnaire des
termes des arts et des sciences et
Corneille définit la zététique de la
façon suivante il dit c'est le fait de
chercher les raisons des choses
et sa définition correspond parfaitement
à l'étymologie du mot puisque zététiques
ça vient de zetane en grec qui veut dire
chercher enquêter
le diététicien c'est un enquêteur
et un enquêteur c'est quelqu'un qui
analyse c'est quelqu'un qui décortique
et qui ne tire pas de conclusion avant
d'avoir tout examiné
du moins en théorie
un zététicien c'est quelqu'un qui
cherche une explication rationnelle à ce
qui sort de l'ordinaire
c'est quelqu'un qui lorsque vous
affirmez quelque chose disons ne
surprenant quelque chose qui ne cadre
pas avec l'état actuel des connaissances
va vous dire quels sont vos preuves et
si vous avez des preuves ou en tout cas
si vous avez des éléments qui à vos yeux
constituent des preuves il va vous dire
présenter les mois
présentez les mois et on va les examiner
on va les examiner pour vérifier si ces
preuves en sont vraiment
ou si elles n'ont que l'apparence de
preuves le zététicien c'est un
vérificateur
au sens étymologique de vérifier
établir la vérité
et vérifier ça consiste par exemple à ne
pas confondre preuve et sentiment de
preuve
preuve et conviction
on peut être convaincue de quelque chose
de faux parce qu'il nous manque des
informations parce qu'on a un point de
vue biaisé parce qu'on a un parti pris
idéologique
il y a tout un tas de raisons qui font
qu'on peut croire des choses fausses
c'était pas une question d'intelligence
c'est une question de ressort
psychologique
vous trouverez un grand nombre d'études
qui traitent du sujet de la croyance
chez l'être humain je vous renvoie par
exemple au livre de Thierry Ripoll
pourquoi croient-on qui montre bien que
le phénomène de la croyance touche tout
le monde
y compris les sceptiques quand même
ça c'est très important de l'avoir à
l'esprit ce n'est pas parce qu'on se
déclare sceptique qu'on n'a pas de
croyance
ou qu'on a pas un point de vue orienté
et c'est même d'autant plus dangereux de
se déclarer sceptique ou zététiciens
parce que tôt ou tard la question de
l'influence de nos propres croyances
finira par se poser
et ce n'est pas parce qu'on aura des
années d'expérience dans la critique des
croyances des autres on sera capable de
faire preuve du même esprit critique
s'agissant des nôtres
donc on a tous des croyances des
croyances auxquelles on tient parce
qu'elles font partie de notre identité
parce qu'elle donne du sens à notre vie
et à ce que nous voulons être et croire
qu'on pourrait s'abstraire de nos
croyances c'est très naïf
ce qu'on peut faire en revanche et c'est
ce que propose la zététique c'est
prendre conscience de nos croyances
c'est de comprendre pourquoi on pense se
compense
et parvenir à se dire simplement à se
dire qu'il est possible qu'on fasse
erreur en somme le but de la zététique
c'est l'une des choses les plus
difficiles qui soient pour nous être
humain à savoir se remettre en question
et penser contre soi-même
alors avant d'aller plus loin il y a un
risque de confusion que je voudrais
dissiper dès maintenant et qui concerne
le mot scepticisme parce que j'ai
introduit mon propos en disant qu'en
anglais zététique se disait scepticisome
mais je voudrais être sûr qu'on se
méprenne pas
quand on parle de scepticisme en
philosophie on fait référence à un
mouvement un mouvement de la Grèce
antique qu'on appelle également le
pyronisme du nom de son inventeur Piron
délice et le scepticisme c'était une
vision philosophique du monde qui
consistait à dire que rien n'était vrai
que rien n'était faux que tout était à
la fois vrai et faux autrement dit que
la vérité n'existait pas
l'exercice préféré des sceptiques
c'était la contradiction prendre un
énoncé démontrer qu'il était vrai puis
prendre l'énoncé contraire et de montrer
qu'il était tout aussi vrai
ce qui évidemment va contre la logique
parce que si A est vrai le contraire de
a ne peut pas également être vrai
de la même façon qu'on ne peut pas à la
fois monter les escaliers et les
descendre
sauf dans un cas si vous regardez la
tête en bas
alors ça peut paraître idiot mais c'est
vraiment ce genre d'argument qui était
utilisé par les sceptiques pour
démontrer quelque chose qui pour le coup
n'est pas idiot qui est que tout énoncé
s'inscrit dans un certain référentiel et
que donc si on change de référentiel ce
qui était vrai devient faux et vice et
versa
donc le scepticisme grec c'est l'idée
que la seule vérité c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de vérité
alors est-ce que c'est ça la zététique
est-ce que c'est ce scepticisme là
et bien non pas du tout
la ZX n'est pas le doute hyperbolique
ce n'est pas le doute qui conduit au
nihilisme
la zététique c'est le doute méthodique
c'est le doute raisonner ou raisonnable
autrement dit pour le diététiciens le
doute n'est pas une fin en soi
c'est un préalable c'est un prérequis
dont la finalité est de parvenir à la
vérité ou tout du moins à l'exactitude
à se rapprocher de l'exactitude si on
veut être tout à fait rigoureux
en cela la zététique a pour ancêtre
n'ont pas le scepticisme grec mais
plutôt le doute cartésien
dans le Discours de la méthode Descartes
explique qu'il s'est rendu compte que
beaucoup de choses qu'il avait apprises
depuis son enfance que ce soit à l'école
que ce soit dans les livres ou même
simplement des informations rapportées
que beaucoup de ces choses s'étaient
révèle les fausses
et ça ça lui a vraiment posé problème
parce qu'il s'est dit je peux croire des
choses fausses
et non seulement je peux croire des
choses fausses mais en plus je peux être
absolument convaincu que ces choses
fausses sont vraies
quand on croit quelque chose par
définition on croit que ce qu'on croit
est vrai sinon on ne le croirait pas
croire c'est croire qu'on a raison de
croire
autrement dit des cartes a pris
conscience qu'il y avait une différence
entre certitude et vérité et du fait
qu'on ne pouvait pas se fier à sa
certitude pour établir la vérité d'une
information
la certitude ça suffit pas
le sentiment de vérité n'est pas un
critère de vérité
donc comment faire pour savoir si ce que
l'on croit est réellement vrai
la réponse de Descartes c'est qu'il faut
utiliser sa raison
remplacer le sentiment de certitude par
l'analyse rationnelle
parce que la raison est un outil neutre
si je dis que 2 + 2 = 4 ce n'est pas un
sentiment personnel
et même si ça me dérange même si je n'ai
pas envie que de plus de égal 4 la
raison m'oblige à l'accepter la raison
elle se moque de nos préférences
elle se moque de nos désirs elle analyse
elle déduit et elle conclut point
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que quand
on est émotionnellement impliqué dans
une croyance quand on tient
personnellement à ce que cette croyance
soit vraie parce que sa réponse à un
besoin psychologique ou idéologique ça
devient très difficile de juger
rationnellement
devient de mauvaise foi on va tordre la
raison on va tirer dessus comme un
élastique pour tenter de faire passer
pour un jugement rationnel ce qui est en
fait un besoin irrationnel
un besoin des tripes pour reprendre
l'expression d'Henry broch
donc pour en revenir à Descartes des
cartes nous dit qu'il faut douter de
tout ce que l'on croit être vrai qu'il
faut pratiquer l'examen critique de nos
croyances et ne tenir pour vrai que ce
qui aura été hors de doute par la raison
la différence entre Descartes et la
zététique c'est le champ d'application
de ce doute
un diététicien ne va pas douter de tout
il ne va pas douter du fait que la
réalité existe
il ne va pas douter de sa propre
existence
donc de quoi va douter le diététicien
le diététicien va douter prioritairement
je dis bien prioritairement de tout ce
qui contredit ce que l'on sait de la
réalité
je répète le zététicien va douter de
tout ce qui contredit ce que l'on sait
de la réalité
alors là je sens qu'il va y avoir des
objections
que c'est un peu vague
ça veut dire quoi ce que l'on sait de la
réalité
c'est qui
ça veut dire quoi savoir
on ben c'est la science plus précisément
l'état actuel de la science
ce qu'on appelle l'état de l'art l'état
de l'art c'est l'ensemble des
connaissances accumulées sur un sujet
dont on dispose à un instant donné
donc par exemple l'état de l'art sur la
télépathie la transcommunication comme
on l'appelle c'est de dire que ça
n'existe pas
qu'on ne dispose pas de preuves
scientifiques allant dans le sens de la
réalité d'un tel phénomène
pareil pour l'astrologie pareil pour la
numérologie ou pour l'ufologie l'étude
des ovnis
aucune preuve qui viennent donner à ses
disciplines un crédit scientifique
malgré le fait qu'elle s'attribue le
suffixe logis qui en français indique
qu'on parle d'une science
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
on les appelle des pseudosciences c'est
à dire les sciences qui n'en sont pas
alors soyons quand même rigoureux le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas de preuve
scientifique d'un phénomène ça ne
signifie pas que ce phénomène n'existe
pas
il y a une phrase qui revient souvent
auxététique qui est l'absence de preuve
n'est pas la preuve de l'absence
pour une raison simple qui est qu'on ne
peut pas prouver l'inexistence d'une
chose
dit que quelque part dans l'univers il
existe un animal qui possède trois têtes
12 pattes qui crachent du feu et qui a
l'accent belge si vous le trouvez pas je
pourrais toujours vous répondre que vous
avez mal cherché
donc on ne peut pas prouver qu'une chose
n'existe pas en revanche ce que dit la
zététique c'est que la charge de la
preuve un combat celui qui affirme
l'existence
pas celui qui doute
si vous pensez qu'il existe
effectivement un tel animal quelque part
dans l'univers c'est à vous de le
démontrer
ce n'est pas à votre interlocuteur de
démontrer l'inverse
sinon vous commettez ce qu'on appelle
une inversion de la charge de la preuve
de la même façon qu'au tribunal on ne
demande pas l'accusé de prouver qu'il
est innocent on demande à l'accusation
de prouver qu'il est coupable
c'est dans ce sens là que ça marche
donc l'absence de preuve n'est pas la
preuve de l'absence en revanche ce que
dit la zététique c'est quand l'absence
de preuve il n'y a pas de raison de
croire
le zététicien ne dira pas telle chose
n'existe pas il ne dira pas ce que vous
dites est faux il dira quelle bonne
raison me donnez-vous d'y croire
si je n'ai pas de bonne raison d'y
croire je n'y crois pas
autrement dit pour un diététicien le
doute est une position par défaut je
doute parce que je ne veux pas prendre
le risque de vous croire sur parole
non pas que je ne vous fasse pas
confiance mais parce que la parole n'est
pas une preuve
pour croire j'ai besoin de preuves
et quand j'aurai des preuves quand
j'aurai des éléments tangibles je
réévaluerai ma position
en attendant je suspends mon jugement
donc dans la phrase le zététicien doute
de ce qui contredisent qu'on sait de la
réalité
on c'est la science
plus précisément l'état actuel des
connaissances scientifiques
maintenant le mot savoir et bien
justement science ça veut dire savoir
tirer en latin et ce qui est c'est scier
c'est trancher trancher quoi trancher le
vrai du faux
tranché ce qui relève de la connaissance
de ce qui relève de la croyance
parce qu'elle est là la distinction
fondamentale de la zététique la
distinction entre croyance et
connaissance
la distinction entre ce qui a l'air vrai
ou ce qu'on voudrait être vrai est-ce
qui a été démontré comme vrai
et qu'est-ce qui permet de trancher
entre croyances et connaissances
c'est la méthode scientifique
la méthode scientifique au sens où on
parle de science de nos jours parce que
la science n'a pas toujours été scalée
elle a évolué et il y a beaucoup de
choses qui étaient considérées comme
scientifique dans l'Antiquité qui ne
sont plus du tout considérés comme
scientifiques aujourd'hui mais la
méthode scientifique au sens moderne
c'est une méthode qui repose sur deux
principes des principes qu'on appelle
épistémologiques
épistémologique c'est-à-dire qu'il
permette de produire de la connaissance
ces deux principes sont le matérialisme
et le rationalisme
je voudrais qu'on prenne le temps de
s'arrêter sur ces deux principes parce
que vous allez voir que ça permet
d'éclairer beaucoup de choses
on va commencer par le matérialisme
le matérialisme c'est la vision du monde
qui considère que tout est matière
que le monde les planètes les astres
mais aussi les êtres vivants les
végétaux les animaux les êtres humains
que tout ça c'est de la matière
que ce n'est que de la matière
les atomes des cellules des protéines de
la matière ou des interactions de
matière
par exemple la gravitation ce n'est pas
de la matière mais c'est le résultat
d'une interaction de matière
des masques qui s'attirent
l'électromagnétisme c'est l'interaction
entre des charges électriques et des
champs électromagnétiques
donc dans une vision du monde
matérialiste tout ce qui existe tout ce
qui compose le monde et de nature
matérielle
et alors là vous allez me dire oui mais
il existe des choses qui ne sont pas de
nature matérielle par exemple la
conscience
par exemple les sentiments ou les
émotions et bien pour la science ça
aussi c'est de la matière
ce sont des émanations de la matière
des émanations c'est à dire des
productions
la conscience c'est une émanation du
cerveau des neurones or le cerveau les
neurones tout ça c'est de la matière
pareil pour les sentiments on imagine
les sentiments comme quelque chose
d'immatériel parce que le sentiment il
n'a pas de forme il n'a pas de contour
il n'a pas de masse
ou n'est sauf que le sentiment c'est le
résultat d'un processus chimique
et la chimie c'est de la matière donc
sur le plan philosophique la science
moderne et matérialiste au sens où elle
considère qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté
l'esprit et d'un autre côté la matière
elle considère que l'esprit provient de
la matière
la science n'est pas dualiste elle est
moniste
et donc elle considère que si les
phénomènes spirituels existent bel et
bien ils ne sont que des émanations de
phénomènes matériels
donc là je pense que vous aurez compris
où je veux en venir dire que la science
est matérialiste ça signifie que du
point de vue de la science ce qu'on
appelle les phénomènes Spirit c'est pas
possible
que la médiumnité la réincarnation les
fantômes que ces phénomènes n'ont pas de
réalité scientifique
parce que c'est phénomènes supposent une
indépendance de l'esprit par rapport à
la matière
or dans une approche matérialiste du
monde l'esprit n'existe pas sans la
matière
puisqu'il en est une émanation et même
dans l'hypothèse ou l'esprit existerait
sans la matière si on n'a pas de preuve
on peut pas affirmer que ça existe
ce que veut la science ce sont des
preuves
la science ne veut pas croire
elle veut voir elle veut observer
mesurer elle est fondamentalement
empiriste
autrement dit elle ne peut étudier que
ce qui peut faire l'objet d'une
observation
alors évidemment c'est un peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue parce que si la
science a besoin de preuve matérielles
mais que les phénomènes spirits sont par
essence immatériels l'épreuve elles
arriveront jamais
à moins qu'on puisse observer des
manifestations matérielles de ces
entités spirituelles
c'est d'ailleurs ce que prétendent les
tenants du spiritisme que les esprits se
manifestent
vous avez sans doute tous déjà joué au
Ouija le Ouija c'est cette planche
composée de lettres et de chiffres on
place un verre retourné sur la planche
on invoque un esprit et on lui pose des
questions
et l'esprit répond en faisant glisser le
verre sur les lettres
donc ça ce serait une bonne expérience
pour vérifier l'existence de ces entités
l'ennui c'est qu'à chaque fois que ce
genre d'expérience a été contrôlé par
des scientifiques ça rien donné ou
plutôt on constatait que ce n'était pas
un esprit qui déplaçait le verre mais
que c'était en fait l'un des
participants qui le poussait
inconsciemment on appelle ça l'effet
idéomoteur
mais comprenez bien que même si c'était
effectivement un esprit qui déplaçait le
verre d'un point de vue scientifique ce
serait très compliqué à prouver
et donc à admettre
parce qu'une science matérialiste voudra
toujours épuiser toutes les explications
matérielles avant de pouvoir envisager
une explication spirituelle
et si la science ne trouve pas
d'explications matérielle sa conclusion
ne sera pas de dire qu'il s'agit d'un
phénomène d'origine spirituelle
sa conclusion sera de dire qu'il s'agit
d'un phénomène matériel d'origine
inconnue pourquoi parce que son
épistémologie parce que sa vision
matérialiste du monde fait que
structurellement elle ne peut pas
concevoir une origine non matérielle un
phénomène matériel
donc ça c'est le premier principe
épistémologique de la science moderne le
matérialisme
le deuxième principe épistémologique de
la science c'est le rationalisme
le rationalisme c'est l'idée comme son
nom l'indique que tout est rationnel
autrement dit c'est l'idée qu'il
n'existent rien qui n'échappe aux lois
de la raison et de la logique
la première loi de la rationalité étant
la loi de causalité
la loi de causalité c'est la loi qui
nous dit que tout ce qui arrive et même
que tout ce qui existe et l'effet d'une
cause ou d'une combinaison de cause
autrement dit qu'il n'y a pas d'effet
sans cause et qu'un effet ne peut pas
être antérieur à sa cause
c'est important parce que dans la liste
des phénomènes paranormaux on trouve des
choses qui vont à l'encontre du principe
de rationalité
par exemple les miracles
un miracle c'est un phénomène
extraordinaire un phénomène en apparence
irrationnel dans lequel on reconnaît la
marque d'une intervention divine
c'est la scène de Pulp Fiction dans
laquelle Vincent et Jules se font tirer
dessus quasiment à bout portant et aucun
d'eux n'est touché et ça pour Jules
c'est un miracle
une intervention de Dieu en personne
parce que c'est contraire à toutes les
lois de la raison
or il n'y a que Dieu qui puisse mettre
en pause les lois de la raison
bon bah ça pour Vincent le sceptique
c'est pas satisfaisant
il n'a pas de contrepexplication à lui
opposer parce qu'effectivement c'est
très étrange mais un miracle il n'y
croit pas
d'ailleurs sa réponse est révélatrice
c'est bizarre mais ça arrive
ça arrive sous-entendu il existe une
explication rationnelle
pour Jules Vincent est aveugle
il refuse de voir qu'il y a eu un
miracle
pour Vincent c'est Jules qui est aveugle
parce qu'il refuse de voir qu'il y a
toujours une explication rationnelle
dire que la science est rationaliste
c'est dire que si vous êtes témoin d'un
miracle le scientifique ne va pas
s'arrêter à votre témoignage
il va chercher les causes de ce miracle
et entendu qu'une fois qu'on a identifié
les causes d'un miracle ce miracle cesse
d'en être un
miracle rationnel c'est un oxymore
soit c'est un miracle donc ce n'est pas
rationnel soit c'est rationnel donc ce
n'est plus un miracle
et c'est là qu'il faut introduire un
concept absolument fondamental pour
comprendre la distinction entre science
et croyances qui est le concept de
surnature
quand on parle d'événements
extraordinaire comme les miracles ou
comme les apparitions de la Vierge on
parle de phénomène surnaturel
surnaturel ça sous-entend qu'il y aurait
quelque chose au-dessus de la nature
quelque chose qui échapperait aux lois
de notre nature
et donc aux lois de notre rationalité
étant entendu que nous avons la
rationalité de notre nature
nous appelons rationnel ce qui
correspond au fonctionnement de notre
univers
dans un monde où les lois de la nature
serait différente la rationalité aussi
serait différente
par exemple si on imagine un univers où
le temps irait à l'envers
rajeunir ce serait pas irrationnel
ce serait normal
ce serait logique
c'est vieillir qui serait irrationnel
donc tout ça pour dire que le concept de
rationalité dépend des lois de notre
nature mais que si on imagine une
surnature si on imagine un univers ou
une dimension qui n'obéirait pas au même
loi tout devient possible
le problème c'est que pour la science il
n'y a pas de surnature
il n'y a que de là nature
de la nature Explorer ou inexploré
connu ou inconnu mais pas de surnature
parler de surnature c'est encore une
fois établir un dualisme
et ses confondre l'inexpliqué et
l'inexplicable
inexplicable ça veut dire qu'on pourra
jamais comprendre
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'un phénomène
est inexpliqué qu'il est inexplicable
c'est simplement qu'on n'a pas encore
trouvé d'explication
parce que l'esprit humain est imparfait
parce que la nature est complexe et
parce qu'il faut du temps
mais invoquer une cause surnaturelle au
prétexte qu'on n'a pas encore trouvé
d'explication d'un point de vue
scientifique c'est brûler les étapes
et surtout c'est utiliser l'argument de
l'ignorance pour s'interdire de chercher
à comprendre ce qui a forcément une
cause rationnelle
donc voilà résumé les deux grands
principes épistémologiques de la science
moderne le matérialisme et le
rationalisme
maintenant on va quand même prendre le
temps de se pencher sur les limites de
ces deux principes
sur les limites de l'épistémologie
scientifique moderne
parce que la science a des limites et
c'est important d'en avoir conscience
déjà pour ne pas attendre de la chance
des choses qui ne sont pas dans ses
capacités qui ne sont pas dans son
cahier des charges si on peut dire et
aussi à contrario pour ne pas absolument
utiliser la science
pour ne pas s'enfermer dans ce qu'on
appelle le scientisme
c'est-à-dire dans l'idée que la science
a réponse à tout
autrement dit on va faire nous-mêmes un
travail de zététiciens un travail
d'examen critique pour comprendre
quelles sont les faiblesses du modèle
scientifique après quoi on montrera en
quoi ces faiblesses ont quand même un
intérêt
alors on va commencer par les faiblesses
du matérialisme
rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure on a dit que pour la science
tous les phénomènes étaient de nature
matérielle et que donc pour qu'un
phénomène soit considéré comme réel
comme existant il fallait pouvoir en
faire l'observation
à ça on pourrait répondre que dans
l'histoire des sciences il y a des tas
de choses qui se sont révélées réelles
alors qu'elle n'avait fait l'objet
d'aucune observation
par exemple les ondes électromagnétiques
quand les rayons ultraviolets ont été
découverts c'était au début du XIXe
siècle on venait de découvrir quelque
chose qu'aucun être humain n'avait
jamais perçu
pareil pour les infrarouges pareil pour
les ultrasons
vous imaginez à l'époque c'est quelqu'un
avait dit il existe des couleurs mais on
n'est pas capable de les voir il existe
des sons mais on n'est pas capable de
les entendre n'importe quels
esthéticiens aurait répondu quelles sont
vos sources
pas de preuve pas de raison de croire
ce qui est pas faux dans l'absolu mais
ça veut bien dire qu'il y a une limite à
l'approche matérialiste du monde
et cette limite c'est la détection
la détection de ce qui a une existence
réelle mais qui sort de notre cadre de
perception
nos instruments de détection on les
conçoit pour détecter des choses dont on
sait déjà qu'elles existent
bah oui pas pour détecter des choses
dont on ignore l'existence
ce qui veut dire qu'à l'heure où nous
parlons il existe des tas de phénomènes
physiques que nous ignorons parce qu'on
ne possède pas les outils pour les
détecter
et le jour où on sera capable de les
détecter dans 20 ans dans 100 ans ou
dans 1000 ans on se rendra compte que
certains phénomènes qu'on range
actuellement dans la case paranormale et
pseudo-science était en fait des
phénomènes réels et parfaitement
scientifiques qui attendait juste d'être
détecté
ça ne veut évidemment pas dire qu'il
faut croire dans des choses qu'on n'a
pas observé ça veut dire qu'il faut
laisser la porte entrouverte à la
possibilité de leur existence
autrement dit de ne pas faire de notre
ignorance la preuve d'une absence
laisser entrouverte la possibilité c'est
simplement avoir conscience de la
relativité de notre savoir et accepter
l'idée que ce que nous ignorons est
infiniment plus vaste que ce que nous
connaissons et à l'inverse ne pas
laisser cette porte entrouverte c'est
transformer la science en dogme
soit le contraire exact de la démarche
scientifique
maintenant deuxième faiblesse qui
concerne cette fois le rationalisme
on l'a dit la science repose sur la
rationalité et la clé de voûte de la
rationalité c'est la loi de causalité
seulement voilà il se trouve que notre
conception de la causalité selon
laquelle un effet serait toujours
précédé dans le temps par sa cause n'est
pas valable de façon aussi absolue qu'on
voudrait le croire
on va prendre un exemple
en 1935 il y a eu une polémique entre
Albert Einstein et nilsborg portant sur
le fait que si on prend un système de
deux particules et qu'on en modifie une
la deuxième particule va subir la même
modification
instantanément et ce même si elle est
située à des milliers de kilomètres de
la première
ça c'est quelque chose qui a été prouvé
depuis ça a été observé notamment grâce
aux expériences d'Alain Aspect ça
s'appelle le phénomène d'intrication
quantique
et ça Einstein n'y croyait pas il n'y
croyait pas parce que ça allait à
l'encontre de la loi de causalité
plutôt de sa conception de la loi de
causalité qui veut que pour qu'une
information soit transmise d'une
particule à une autre bah il faut du
temps
même si l'information circule à la
vitesse de la lumière il faut quand même
du temps
or là ce qui était dit c'est que
l'information se transmettait de manière
instantanée
autrement dit que l'effet et la cause
était simultanée
alors faut savoir que cette polémique
entre Albert Einstein et nielsborg a
duré plus de 20 ans et qu'on n'était pas
seulement sur une querelle scientifique
on était sur une querelle philosophique
une chorale philosophique sur la nature
de la réalité et donc sur la nature des
lois qui régissent la réalité
il s'est avéré que c'est nilsborg qui
avait raison que les faits lui ont donné
raison autrement dit qu'il était
possible qu'un effet soit simultané à sa
cause
est-ce qu'il faut comprendre au travers
de cette anecdote c'est que dans sa
conception à lui de la causalité
einstein n'avait pas tort c'est juste
que ce phénomène d'intrication lui
paraissait contraire à la loi de
causalité
en d'autres termes Einstein avait une
conception classique de la causalité
parce qu'il avait une conception
classique de la physique
d'ailleurs s'amusant parce que
savez-vous quel surnom Einstein avait
donné à l'intrication quantique
à laquelle il ne croyait pas il appelait
ça action fantomatique à distance
fantomatique pour s'en moquer parce que
pour lui ce que disait nicksborg c'était
plus de la science
c'était de la magie
c'était du spiritisme le spiritisme dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
donc le spiritisme des uns et la science
des autres
c'est une question de contexte
épistémologique
donc quand on dit la causalité en
réalité on fait déjà une erreur
parce qu'on identifie la causalité à
notre compréhension de la causalité
et ça c'est très important à comprendre
si on veut éviter de réduire la
rationalité et donc la science à notre
conception de la rationalité
la rationalité de l'univers est beaucoup
plus subtile qu'on l'imagine
avant de passer à la suite il y a un
troisième point sur lequel il faudrait
dire un mot et qui concerne ce qu'on
appelle le consensus scientifique
un zététicien c'est quelqu'un qui vous
dira pour se faire une opinion éclairée
sur un sujet il faut consulter le
consensus scientifique
le consensus scientifique c'est lorsque
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
et d'accord sur un domaine particulier
de la recherche
par exemple il y a un consensus
scientifique sur le fait que la terre
est ronde il y a un consensus
scientifique sur l'évolution
sur le Big Bang
consensus scientifique ça ne veut pas
dire qu'absolument tous les
scientifiques sont d'accord ça veut dire
que l'écrasante majorité est d'accord
mais il y a aussi des sujets sur
lesquels il n'y a pas de consensus par
exemple sur l'origine de la vie on ne
sait pas
par exemple sur ce qui a précédé le Big
Bang on ne sait pas en cosmologie les
débats sont très nombreux le modèle
standard souffre de plusieurs lacunes
la matière noire n'est qu'une hypothèse
les trous noirs on sait pas vraiment ce
que c'est donc il faut être prudent
quand on parle de connaissance
scientifique parce que beaucoup de
choses ne font pas consensus
de la même façon il y a des choses qui
faisaient consensus à une époque et qui
ont été balayés par la suite les choses
que la science croyait vrai et que cette
même science a fini par abandonner alors
je veux pas parler Galilée parce qu'en
réalité les tests de Galilée c'était
surtout l'église qui les contestait
mais on pourrait parler de l'expansion
de l'Univers pendant très longtemps le
consensus scientifique c'était de dire
que l'Univers était stationnaire ce que
croyait d'ailleurs Einstein encore lui
on pourrait aussi parler de la théorie
des races qui étaient encore enseignée à
l'université au 20e siècle
et à l'inverse il y a des choses que le
consensus scientifique rejeté jusqu'à
récemment et qui ont fini par être
accepté par exemple l'hypnose
pendant très longtemps l'hypnose c'était
considéré comme pseudo science
une science occultes comme on dit à
l'époque
si bien que jusqu'à récemment et même
encore de nos jours quand on vous
parlait d'hypnose la réponse était
souvent moi l'hypnose j'y crois pas
j'y crois pas comme si c'était une
question de croyance et sauf que
l'hypnose ce n'est pas une question de
croyance
c'est une réalité une réalité
scientifique
on fait des opérations chirurgicales
sous hypnose en fait des accouchements
sous hypnose
et ça se passe très bien
alors tout le monde n'est pas réceptif
et c'est justement ça qui pose problème
à la science le fait qu'il y ait une
grande part d'un détermination mais le
fait est que l'hypnose est passé de la
case pseudo-sciences à la case sciences
donc si on appliquait bêtement
l'argument du consensus scientifique
maintenant c'est à dire en faisant
abstraction du caractère évolutif des
connaissances scientifiques la science
ne progresserait pas
et si on répond oui mais aujourd'hui on
sait alors qu'il y a 100 ans on ne
savait pas bah c'est bien la preuve que
le consensus scientifique n'est jamais
définitif
dans 100 ans on se penchera sur nos
connaissances actuelles et on dira mon
Dieu qu'ils étaient bêtes
il n'avait pas compris ça
mais nous on sait
et sans plus tard ça recommencera
donc si on récapitule premièrement
absence de consensus scientifique sur de
nombreux sujets
deuxièmement évolution du consensus
scientifique dans le temps et
troisièmement ce qu'on a vu dans notre
épisode sur Thomas Coon les paradigmes
toutes recherches scientifique s'inscrit
dans un paradigme qui n'est pas éternel
un paradigme c'est une certaine vision
du monde et l'histoire de la science
c'est le passage d'un paradigme à un
autre on en a eu un exemple tout à
l'heure avec la physique quantique la
physique quantique ça a été une
révolution en sciences après la physique
quantique on ne voyait plus le monde de
la même façon
donc non seulement le consensus
scientifique peut évoluer au sein d'un
même paradigme exemple l'atome au début
du 20e siècle on pensait que l'atome
était une particule indivisible ce qui
s'est révélé faux mais en plus le
consensus scientifique évolue
nécessairement quand il y a changement
de paradigme la physique quantique
donc vous voyez bien maintenant je pense
que quand on dit la science ça veut tout
et rien dire
parce que c'est quoi la science
si la science est seulement le consensus
scientifique actuel on a vu que ça
posait beaucoup de problèmes
maintenant si la science c'est le
processus historique d'acquisition et
d'amélioration des connaissances qui
passent par des évolutions qui passent
par des remises en question qui passe
par des crises et des corrections là ça
a du sens
pourquoi parler de tout ça pour ne pas
tomber dans une fausse compréhension de
la zététique dans une vision
caricaturale et enfantine de la
zététique qui serait ils étaient tiques
arrogantes et dogmatique
zététique qui confondrait science et
état actuel des connaissances
ils étaient qui oublieraient que le
propre de la science c'est l'évolution
permanente
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que les
faiblesses de la science moderne pouvait
avoir un intérêt
cet intérêt tient en un mot
la prudence
la science moderne est prudente
elle ne veut tenir pour vrai que ce qui
aura été vérifié comme étant vrai
pas ce qui est possible
pas ce qui est envisageable
ce qui est vérifié
donc en se limitant au phénomène
matériel et rationnel la science se
limite à ce qui peut être vérifié
à ce qui peut être vérifié par tout le
monde
un phénomène matériel on peut le mesurer
objectivement
on peut le tester à travers des
expériences
donc c'est solide
la rationalité c'est ce qui fait qu'on
comprend pourquoi tel cause produit tel
effet ça aussi c'est solide
donc en se limitant au phénomène
matériel et rationnel la science passe
probablement à côté de nouvelles
connaissances
mais les connaissances qu'elle produit
elle sait pourquoi elle les produit
donc oui la science progresse lentement
mais sa lenteur et la condition de la
garantie de ces résultats
comme dit l'adage prudence et mère de
sûreté
les conclusions de la science ne
correspondent peut-être pas à la
véritable absolue mais elles sont
corroborées par suffisamment d'éléments
pour qu'on ne la réduise pas à une
simple opinion pour qu'on se dise c'est
du solide
solide ne veut pas dire indestructible
ça veut dire que si on veut détrôner une
connaissance scientifique il va falloir
venir avec des éléments encore plus
solides
la deuxième chose c'est que si la
science fait effectivement des erreurs
l'une de ses vertus c'est qu'elle est
auto correctrice
elle apprend de ses erreurs
parce que quand l'expérience lui montre
qu'elle a tort elle n'a pas le choix
elle doit se corriger
elle doit admettre qu'elle s'était
trompée
la science ne peut pas persister
indéfiniment dans l'erreur
donc là encore ça peut prendre du temps
mais tôt ou tard elle finit par se
mettre à jour
comme je le disais tout à l'heure la
science ce n'est pas un dogme c'est
conclusions ne sont pas gravées dans le
marbre
sinon c'était plus la science c'est de
la religion
mais ce qui fait qu'on peut avoir
confiance dans la science c'est le fait
qu'elle repose sur une méthode
une méthode qui fait que si on est dans
l'erreur on va être obligé de s'en
rendre compte
et donc de corriger l'erreur
ou en tout cas d'essayer
dans l'art du doute Henry Broch décrit
les trois étapes de la méthode
scientifique
ces trois étapes sont les suivantes
induction déduction rétroaction
on peut le dire plus simplement
observation hypothèse expérience
tout part de l'observation l'observation
des faits très souvent la séparation
entre science et pseudo-science a lieu
ici une erreur d'observation
une erreur de jugement sur ce qui est
observé parce que les perceptions sont
trompeuses on croit avoir une flaque
d'eau sur la route et alors qu'on
s'approche la flaque d'eau disparaît
c'était un mirage il y a un principe en
science qu'on a baptisé La dentor de
Fontenelle la tendeur de Fontenelle
c'est un texte écrit au XVIIe siècle qui
raconte qu'un jour un enfant de 7 ans ce
serait réveillé avec une dent en or et
absolument personne ne comprenait
comment c'était possible donc chacun y
allait de sa petite théorie et bien
entendu la théorie qu'il a emporté c'est
Dieu
c'est Dieu qui avait fait pousser une
dent en or dans la mâchoire de cet
enfant
le problème nous dit font-elle c'est que
cette histoire n'a jamais eu lieu
cette dent en or n'a jamais existé donc
on a construit des théories on a
construit des raisonnements et des
démonstrations pour tenter d'expliquer
quelque chose qui n'était pas arrivé qui
n'était pas factuel le principe de la
dent d'ordre de Fontenelles c'est
conscience il faut toujours s'assurer du
fait avant de vouloir trouver la cause
et si on élimine tout ce qui n'est pas
de l'ordre du fait si on élimine tout ce
qui est dû à une erreur de perception au
témoignage à la rumeur on se retrouve
déjà avec beaucoup moins de matière à
analyser
la deuxième étape de la méthode
scientifique c'est l'hypothèse
pourquoi ce qui se produit se produit
la zététique recommande de toujours
privilégier l'hypothèse la moins
coûteuse celle qui implique le moins
d'éléments inconnus possible
on appelle ça le principe de parcimonie
si votre verre tombe par terre vous
pouvez faire l'hypothèse que des petits
lutins invisibles tirent sur les objets
avec des cordes elles aussi invisibles
et qui se sont amusés à envoyer votre
verre par terre pour vous énerver
mais vous pouvez faire une hypothèse
plus simple plus par simonieuse qui est
de dire que vous l'avez simplement
laissé échapper et que la gravité a fait
le reste
principe de parcimonie aussi appelé le
rasoir d'okham du nom de Guillaume
d'ocam un philosophe du 14e siècle qui
disait les multiples ne doivent pas être
utilisés sans nécessité traduction
toujours aller vers l'explication la
plus simple toujours aller vers
l'hypothèse qui nous fait économiser les
inconnus
ça ne veut pas dire que l'explication la
plus simple est forcément la bonne ça
veut dire qu'il faut procéder avec
méthode
commencer par ce qui paraît le plus
vraisemblable et si ça ne fonctionne pas
allez vers des options plus complexes
alors attention un piège dans lequel il
ne faut surtout pas tomber ce serait de
croire que ce principe marche à tous les
coups non le principe de parcimonie ça
marche pas à tous les coups
dans l'Antiquité le principe de
parcimonie ça consiste à faire
l'hypothèse que la terre était immobile
et que c'était les astres qui se
déplaçaient autour d'elle c'était ça
l'hypothèse la moins coûteuse et
pourtant c'était faux
quand on a découvert les neutrinos dans
les années 50 l'hypothèse la plus
parcimonieuse c'était de dire que les
neutrinos n'avaient pas de masse parce
que s'ils avaient une masse ça obligé à
modifier l'intégralité du modèle
cosmologique standard
il s'est avéré que les neutrinos avaient
une masse et donc il a fallu changer le
modèle
donc le principe de parcimonie ne
conduit pas nécessairement à la vérité
le principe de parcimonie c'est un guide
méthodologique qui permet de faciliter
la pratique de la science
un peu comme quand on perd ses clés et
qu'avant d'aller les chercher à 800 km
on commence par regarder sous les
coussins du canapé ça ne veut pas dire
que les clés sont forcément sous les
coussins du canapé ça veut dire qu'il
est plus raisonnable d'envisager d'abord
cette hypothèse plutôt que d'envisager
une hypothèse plus coûteuse
donc la méthode ne dit pas ce qui est
vrai elle nous dit comment avoir le plus
de chance d'arriver à des conclusions
juste
c'est une simple question probabilité
plus on multiplie les variables
inconnues plus on adresse de s'éloigner
de la vérité
plus on les réduit plus on a de chance
de s'en rapprocher
mais l'histoire des sciences c'est aussi
l'histoire de découverte imprévues
intéressez-vous à ce qu'on appelle la
sert en dépité
assez en dépité c'est le fait de
découvrir quelque chose de nouveau de
manière accidentelle
autrement dit sans passer par les cases
de la méthode
on étudie un phénomène et on remarque
quelque chose d'anormal
anormal par rapport à ce qui était prévu
et cette anomalie va ouvrir un nouveau
champ de découverte
parce que il faut bien qu'il y ait de
l'inattendu pour qu'il y ait découverte
la radioactivité a été découverte par
sérendipité
la thermodynamique a été découverte par
ces rangs
il y a de la place pour l'imprévu et
même pour le hasard
et rejetez une hypothèse ou rejeter une
découverte au motif qu'elle n'a pas été
obtenu en suivant la méthode ce n'est
plus de la science
c'est du conservatisme
du conservatisme délétère pour la
science
la science c'est aussi une aventure au
sens étymologique
ce qui arrive
qui advient
ce qui advient sans qu'on les prévu
donc prenons bien garde à ne pas
confondre zététique et conservatisme
scientifique
la zététique c'est l'utilisation d'une
méthode pour favoriser et faciliter la
production de connaissances
le conservatisme scientifique c'est le
rejet de tout ce qui dévie de la méthode
scientifique et qui parle à même fait
obstruction à de nouvelles découvertes
et puis de toute façon la troisième
étape de la méthode scientifique décrite
par Henry Brock et censé mettre tout le
monde d'accord
l'étape du test
l'expérience plus exactement
l'expérimentation c'est à dire
l'expérience répétée
parce qu'une expérience isolée ne prouve
rien
si vous lancez une pièce en l'air et
qu'elle retombe sur pile vous n'allez
pas en conclure qu'une pièce tombe
toujours sur pile vous allez répéter
l'expérience la répéter et la répéter à
nouveau jusqu'à ce que vous disposiez de
ce qu'on appelle un échantillon
représentatif
et vous allez vous apercevoir qu'au bout
d'un certain nombre de répétitions
d'expérience vous allez avoir 50% de
piles et 50% de face
l'expérimentation repose sur un principe
empirique facile à retenir qui est les
mêmes causes produisent les mêmes effets
or si les mêmes causes produisent les
mêmes effets le fait de répéter
l'expérience dans les mêmes conditions
évidemment pas dans des conditions
différentes parce que sinon vous ne
savez pas quel paramètre a eu quelles
conséquence sur le résultat mais si vous
reproduisez l'expérience dans les mêmes
conditions au bout d'un certain nombre
de répétitions vous savez que votre
résultat est solide qu'il n'est pas dû
au hasard et donc le but du jeu c'est
d'isoler les variables de les contrôler
pour étudier l'influence de chaque
variable sur le résultat
l'idée que les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets et qu'il faut répéter
une expérience pour que ces résultats
soient jugés solides c'est la base de ce
qu'on appelle la reproductibilité
la reproductibilité c'est un concept qui
a été mis en avant par le philosophe des
sciences Carl poppers au 20e siècle même
si en réalité on en trouvait déjà l'idée
chez Francis Bacon au début du XVIIe
siècle et la reproductibilité c'est le
fait que pour qu'un phénomène puisse
être étudié scientifiquement il faut
pouvoir le reproduire dans les mêmes
conditions
par exemple vous voulez étudier
l'efficacité d'une molécule sur un
groupe de passion vous définissez un
protocole et vous faites suivre
exactement le même protocole à tous les
patients alors bien sûr il y aura des
variables individuelles parce que tous
les êtres humains ne réagissent pas
exactement de la même manière à une
molécule mais si vous avez un
échantillon suffisamment représentatif
et qu'en plus de ça vous disposez de ce
qu'on appelle un groupe témoin c'est à
dire un groupe qui n'aura pas reçu la
molécule et qui vous permettra de
comparer l'évolution des deux groupes
bien à ce moment là vous utilisez la
reproductibilité c'est-à-dire que vous
partez du principe que les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets et vous
observez quels sont les effets à grande
échelle de la cause que vous aurez
choisi de tester en l'occurrence la
molécule
chez Carl Popper la reproductibilité va
de pair avec la réfutabilité la
réfutabilité c'est le fait qu'une
théorie peut être qualifiée de
scientifiques si et seulement si il
existe une expérience qui permettrait de
l’invalider je dis bien de l'invalider
pas de la valider
alors ces contre-intuitif mais ça
s'explique
je vais prendre un exemple
imaginez que je vous dise qu'à chaque
fois que vous avez le dos tourné je me
transforme en loup-garou
alors vous allez me dire ok bah dans ce
cas-là on va mettre une caméra et on va
voir si tu transforme en loup-garou
quand j'ai le dos tourné
et là je vais répondre oui même s'il y a
une caméra ça marche pas pour que ça
marche il faut qu'il n'y ait absolument
aucun observateur
ni être humain ni caméra bon bah là
c'est pas réfutable parce que ça veut
dire qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de mettre à
l'épreuve mon affirmation
quoi que je vous propose comme
expérience pour vérifier l'hypothèse il
y aura toujours quelque chose qui n'ira
pas
ma théorie est donc irréfutable au sens
où il n'existe aucune expérience qui
permettrait de l'invalider
elle n'est donc pas scientifique
autrement dit en science
l'infirmation a plus de valeur que la
confirmation
une confirmation n'est pas une preuve
tandis que l'infirmation est une preuve
du contraire
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que pour
survivre l'être humain a besoin
d'oxygène
mais comment vous le savez est-ce que
vous le savez parce que vous constatez
que les êtres humains respirent ou
est-ce que vous le savez parce que si on
prive un être humain d'oxygène il meurt
vous le savez parce que si on prive un
être humain d'oxygène il meurt donc
l'hypothèse les êtres humains ont besoin
d'oxygène et réfutable parce qu'il
existe une expérience qui offre les
conditions de sa réfutation
c'est ça la réputabilité
et si votre hypothèse est réfutable que
vous mettez en place une série
d'expérience pour tenter de la réfuter
et que vous n'y parvenez pas ça voudra
dire que votre hypothèse aura résisté à
la réfutation et si elle a résisté à la
réfutation elle devient une hypothèse
solide
donc là il paradoxe de la démarche
scientifique qui est que pour prouver
quelque chose il faut échouer à prouver
le contraire
une hypothèse devient valide elle
devient vérité au sens de vérifier quand
on échoue à la réfuter
quand on échoue à la faire échouer
donc derrière ces mots un peu compliqués
reproductibilité
réfutabilité il y a en fait quelque
chose d'assez simple à comprendre qui
est que la connaissance c'est le
résultat de l'élimination de la croyance
la croyance peut être un point de départ
mais pour devenir connaissance elle doit
être confrontée à l'expérience
elle doit être mise à l'épreuve des
faits
et c'est à ça que sert la méthode
à éliminer toute trace de subjectivité
à faire en sorte que les résultats de
l'expérimentation ne puissent pas être
influencé par l'expérimentateur
on va dire autrement dans une expérience
le scientifique doit s'effacer
il doit pour ainsi dire disparaître
il n'est que le relais n'est que
l'intermédiaire technique entre des
actions et des réactions
quand un scientifique parle ce n'est pas
lui qui parle
c'est la science qui parle à travers lui
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'objectivité
scientifique même si l'objectivité
intégrale n'existe pas parce que dès
qu'il y a de l'humain il y a de la
subjectivité ne serait-ce que dans la
définition des protocoles mais
l'objectivité scientifique ce n'est pas
l'objectif du scientifique
c'est l'objectif de la méthode
l'impartialité de la méthode
alors on sait qu'il existe une querelle
dans les milieux zététiques sur le fait
de savoir si les sciences sociales sont
de véritables sciences
véritable sens où elles sont beaucoup
moins objectives que les sciences dures
si on prend par exemple la sociologie en
sociologie le sociologue à un point de
vue qui est influencé par sa propre
sociologie
fait contre la sociologie structuraliste
de Pierre Bourdieu et la sociologie
individualiste de Raymond Boudon on va
pas du tout se retrouver avec les mêmes
résultats
et même si carpoper parlait d'une unité
des sciences au sens d'une unité de la
méthodologie scientifique le fait est
qu'on ne peut pas mettre exactement sur
le même plan l'étude scientifique de la
matière et l'étude scientifique des
comportements humains
donc au lieu de parler d'objectivité
scientifique il serait peut juste de
parler de réduction des biais le
zététicien c'est celui qui cherche à
réduire l'influence de ses biais
cognitifs
c'est le fait pour nos jugements d'être
influencé ou orienté
la définition communément admise du
biais cognitif c'est celle du
psychologue Jean-François le nid qui
nous dit un biais est une distorsion que
subit une information en entrant dans le
système cognitif ou en en sortant dans
le premier cas le sujet opère une
sélection des informations dans le
second il réalise une sélection des
réponses
on va prendre un exemple
si je crois être quelqu'un de
sympathique et que je veux vérifier
cette croyance
je ne vais pas demander à mon meilleur
ami est-ce que tu me trouves sympathique
parce que si c'est mon meilleur ami
forcément son jugement va être biaisé
donc il est fort probable qu'il me
réponde oui puisque c'est mon meilleur
ami
ou alors il pourra me répondre oui parce
qu'il ne voudra pas me vexer ou parce
qu'il pense que c'est la réponse que
j'attends donc même si ma question est
clairement formulée je ne pourrais pas
me fier à la réponse parce que la
réponse sera forcément influencée que je
le veuille ou non même si je lui dis
réponds-moi honnêtement un biais
cognitif ça ne se corrige pas sur
demande
un biais cognitif ça peut être par
exemple le biais de confirmation
remarquez les éléments qui confortent
notre croyance et ne pas remarquer les
éléments qui la contredisent
je pars du principe que telle personne
est mauvaise parce qu'elle m'aura fait
une mauvaise première impression et
parce que je parle du principe que cette
personne est mauvaise je ne remarque que
les choses négatives chez elles ou
inversement une bonne première
impression et je ne remarquerai que les
choses positives
donc un biais cognitif c'est tout ce qui
va orienter mon jugement dans un sens ou
dans un autre
de manière souvent inconsciente ou en
tout cas involontaire et qui va
m'éloigner de la réalité des faits
de l'objectivité des faits
et ce que nous dit Henry Broch c'est que
nos biais cognitifs peuvent être
utilisés par certains individus à des
fins de manipulation ou d'exploitation
de notre crédulité
vous êtes quelqu'un de sociable et
d'ouvert aux autres mais en même temps
vous aimez vous retrouver dans votre
bulle vous êtes quelqu'un de courageux
qui travaille pour atteindre ses
objectifs mais il vous arrive d'être
inquiet de douter
mais oui c'est tout à fait moi ça
bah oui
parce que c'est tout le monde en fait
on peut trouver la même chose chez les
médiums vous avez perdu quelqu'un
c'était quelqu'un de proche
quelqu'un qui est parti trop tôt
quelqu'un à qui vous auriez aimé dire
quelque chose avant qu'il parte
vous ressentez parfois sa présence
voyez c'est ça un bien cognitif c'est
tout ce qui fait que vous n'allez pas
recevoir ou émettre une information de
façon neutre
c'est tout ce qui va influencer votre
jugement et le rendre partial
c'est tout ce qui va vous éloigner de
l'objectif et vous isolez dans vos
croyances
donc le travail du zététicien c'est
d'identifier les biais cognitifs à
l'oeuvre dans nos jugements et
évidemment à l'oeuvre dans ces jugements
la synthétique ça ne s'applique pas
seulement aux croyances des autres
ça s'applique aussi et même surtout à
ses propres croyances
je reprendrai ici la distinction qui m'a
été suggéré par Alexis Bellas
l'animateur de la chaîne l'esprit
critique entre la zététique extérieure
et la zététique intérieure
la zététique extérieure c'est celle qui
consiste à corriger le manque d'esprit
critique chez les autres
la zététique intérieure c'est celle qui
consiste à corriger le manque d'esprit
critique chez soi même
parce que pointer les biais cognitifs
chez les autres et restez aveugle aussi
c'est pas de la zététique
c'est de là posture esthétique
c'est eux l'instrumentalisation de la
zététique à des fins de valorisation de
soi
et c'est très important de faire cette
précision parce que sinon c'est la porte
ouverte à toutes les dérives c'est la
porte ouverte à la stigmatisation au
dénigrement à la censure
vous croyez au destin c'est pas très
scientifique ça je vous signale
vous croyez aux vertus de la méditation
je vous signale
au chakra je vous signale
bah oui puisque c'est pas scientifique
mais c'est pas ça la zététique
la zététique ce n'est pas le contrôle
des croyances
la censure des croyances
la zététique ce n'est pas la
stigmatisation des opinions qui
s'écartent du consensus scientifique
avec l'établissement d'un ministère de
la vérité vraie
c'est la mise à disposition d'une
méthode qui permet de savoir c'est ce
que je pense relève d'une croyance ou
d'une connaissance
de la même façon la zététique ce n'est
pas recracher des études scientifiques
ce n'est pas faire de la récitation
sinon on n'est plus quelqu'un qui fait
de la pensée critique
on devient un automate
soit l'inverse exacte de l'esprit
critique
comme le dit en rubroke la zététique ce
n'est pas tant la diffusion des
connaissances scientifiques que la
diffusion de la démarche scientifique
cité des articles scientifiques pour
prouver à l'autre qu'il a tort mais ne
pas savoir pourquoi ce qui est dit dans
l'article est vrai ce n'est pas avoir
une démarche scientifique
que c'est croire aveuglément
croire dans une source d'information
jugée fiable ou croire dans une source
d'information jugée non fiable dans les
deux cas c'est croire
et croire ce n'est pas savoir
dans l'une de ces conférences Étienne
Klein dit nous savons que la terre est
ronde mais nous ne savons pas comment
nous savons
cette phrase lui permettait d'introduire
l'idée que ce que nous appelons
connaissance sont en réalité pour la
plupart d'entre nous des croyances
à proprement parler nous ne savons pas
que la terre est ronde
nous faisons confiance à ceux qui le
savent
nous savons par procuration
mais savoir par procuration ce n'est pas
savoir
parce que c'est récolté le fruit d'une
démarche sans l'avoir ni effectuée ni
comprise
donc combattre les fake news ou
combattre les pseudo-sciences ou
combattre le complotisme c'est une chose
mais diffuser les outils intellectuels
et méthodologiques qui permettent de
distinguer une croyance d'une
connaissance c'est autre chose
et c'est cette différence qui fait qu'on
passe de l'hétéronomie c'est à dire de
la dépendance intellectuelle à une
autorité à l'autonomie c'est à dire à
l'indépendance intellectuelle
former à une méthode plutôt qu'à ses
résultats
formés des esprits libres plutôt que des
esprits qui au lieu d'être soumis à une
pseudo-science seront soumis à la
science sans savoir pourquoi
la zététique c'est faire la démarche de
comprendre pourquoi une chose est vraie
ou fausse
pourquoi une chose est une croyance ou
une connaissance
et ne pas se reposer sur une autorité
aussi digne de confiance soit elle pour
penser à notre place
il y a un dernier danger inhérent à la
zététique un danger dont il faut parler
c'est l'esprit critique à deux vitesses
ce qu'on appelle le double standard et
qui consiste à attaquer les croyances et
les positions idéologiques avec
lesquelles on est en désaccord pour
mieux argumenter en faveur des siennes
faire passer les opinions des autres
pour des erreurs pour des sophisme ou
pour des idées dangereuses et faire
passer ses propres idées pour ne pas
dire ses propres idéaux pour de la
rationalité
pour de la science pour la réalité
toute idéologie se présente comme
correspondant à la réalité
c'est toujours l'idéologie des autres
qui travestit la réalité
quand la zététique n'est plus utilisée
pour contredire des discours fallacieux
mais pour masquer le caractère
fallacieux de notre propre discours
c'est classer éthique est devenue un
outil militant
il y a un nom pour ça ça s'appelle la
rationalisation le fait de justifier par
une prétendue rationalité des discours
et des comportements inspirés par des
motivations non rationnelles
on peut tout justifier au nom de la
rationalité on peut justifier la censure
au nom du fait qu'il y a des idées
dangereuses on peut justifier les camps
d'internement au nom du fait qu'il y a
des individus qui propagent des idées
dangereuses
et les idées dangereuses ce sont les
idées qu'on aura défini soi-même comme
dangereuse
et c'est là qu'il faut préciser quelque
chose de très important
rationnel ne veut pas dire raisonnable
l'URSS prenait la rationalité
l'interdiction de toute religion la
planification économique
l'inspirateur de l'URSS c'était Marx le
socialisme scientifique
donc la rationalité des uns n'est pas la
rationalité des autres la question est
de savoir qu'est-ce qui guide la
rationalité
si c'est le désir d'imposer sa vision du
vrai sa vision du juste sa vision de ce
qui a le droit de s'exprimer ou pas rien
n'empêche la rationalité de devenir un
levier de l'autoritarisme
la zététique c'est être attentif au fait
que quand le désir de propager la vérité
s'empare de nous c'est le signe que la
passion va l'emporter sur la raison
c'est le signe que nous n'allons pas
juger de manière équitable mais que nous
allons tout mettre en œuvre pour faire
passer notre vérité pour la vérité
sans nous rendre compte que ce que nous
croyons être de la raison sera perçu
comme de la raison parce ceux qui
partagent notre conception de la vérité
et sera perçu comme de la malhonnêteté
et comme de la contorsion intellectuelle
parce qu'il la partagent pas
la zététique c'est ne pas confondre
désir de vérité et besoin d'avoir raison
je cite
enseigner dès l'Antiquité la zététique
est basée sur le refus de tout
affirmation dogmatique ce flambeau a été
repris au début des années 1980 pour
expliciter ce qu'est la démarche
scientifique en élaborant comme support
motivant pour des étudiants une approche
scientifique des phénomènes paranormaux
mais la zététique ne se restreint
évidemment pas à ce seul domaine elle
constitue un pilier fondamental du
développement de l'esprit critique au
service de l'ensemble des citoyens car
ces règles d'or sont la base de tout
traité d'autodéfense intellectuelle ce
qu’en disait Pierre Larousse dans son
grand dictionnaire universel du XIXe
siècle semble devoir être rappelé le nom
de zététique qui signifie chercheur
indique une nuance assez originale du
scepticisme c'est le scepticisme
provisoire c'est presque l'idée de
Descartes considérant le doute comme un
moyen non comme une fin comme un procédé
préliminaire non comme un résultat
définitif autrement dit cela peut se
résumer sous l'expression l'art du doute
la considère le doute comme un procédé
une pratique un art d'après la propre
définition du mot art qui est l'ensemble
des moyens des procédés des règles
intéressants une activité une profession
acception presque malheureusement
oublier de nos jours d'ailleurs Pierre
Larousse regrettait que le terme
zététique soit restreint non par le sens
mais par l'usage au sceptique seul alors
qu'il pourrait légitimement être le
terme général désignant tous les
chercheurs de la vérité dans tous les
domaines dans son avertissement sur
l'ensemble de ces leçons pendant le
semestre d'hiver de 1765 à 1766 le
philosophe Emmanuel Kant expliquait
l'importance d'un processus dynamique de
recherche d'informations en précisant
que l'on ne doit à aucun moment
enseigner des pensées mais bien plutôt
apprendre à penser on ne doit pas porter
l'élève disait-il mais bien plutôt le
conduire si l'on désire qu'à l'avenir il
soit en état de marché de lui-même et
quand concluait on plus clairement la
méthode propre de l'enseignement
philosophique et la zététique l'objectif
en utilisant le paranormal comme support
de réflexion et de pouvoir faire
mémoriser plus facilement les règles
scientifiques de base et surtout de
mettre les personnes en capacité de se
les approprier pour les appliquer
concrètement en situation car là et
l'essentiel bien au-delà de toute
discussion épistémologique amené sur le
sujet quelle serait en effet l'intérêt
réel d'un pouvoir ou d'un savoir qu'il
serait pas opératoire ainsi même si
l'approche présente de nombreuses
difficultés l'action vise à définir des
critères permettant si possible de
différencier les champs cognitifs afin
d'établir de tenter d'établir une
démarcation formelle entre science
non-stances et pseudosciences les règles
d'or de la zététique ces règles de
recherche et de vérification d'une
information sont des aides efficaces
permettant de s'assurer de la validité
d'une démarche d'une affirmation ou d'un
résultat mais elle ne garantiss rien un
succès final en effet une recherche
n'est pas simplement dirigée par ou
soumise à des règles elle nécessite
également un soupçon d'intuition un
zeste d'inventivité et une bonne dose
d'imagination et si il finit on bute
tout de même sur quelque chose il ne
faut pas hésiter à différer son jugement
et laisser la question en suspens car
contrairement à ce que l'on pense
souvent la zététique nous enseigne que
le point d'interrogation n'est pas une
marque d'ignorance c'est une marque de
sagesse
la zététique c'est le fait de rechercher
les raisons des choses
quelqu'un qui a une croyance une
croyance irrationnelle il y a des
raisons à cette croyance
des raisons personnelles
liées à son vécu lié à son éducation à
sa psychologie
si tout en cause les croyances aussi ont
une cause
et on annule pas une croyance en la
décrivant comme stupide ou absurde
ce qu'on obtient en faisant ça c'est
juste de la réactance
repli sur ses croyances
et un rejet viscéral de tout ce qui
viendra les contredire
un diététicien qui ne cherchent pas à
comprendre pourquoi l'autre pense ce
qu'il pense mais qui veut simplement lui
dire à quel point ce qu'il pense n'a pas
de sens
ou que c'est contraire aux données
scientifiques
ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui travaille à
propager l'esprit critique
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille à la
consolidation du fossé entre sciences et
croyances
comme le dit Henry Brock plus on
comprendra les causes des croyances
mais on sera capable d'agir sur elle
cette respinosion
le pareil ne pas maudire mais comprendre
comprendre que la zététique ne combat
pas les croyances mais quel combat les
croyances qui se présentent comme
scientifiques les croyances qui se
présentent comme des connaissances
c'est comprendre que nous avons tous des
croyances
qu'elles soient philosophique politique
morale
il n'y a pas de problème avec ça
le problème c'est lorsque l'esprit
critique ne sert plus à remettre en
question ces croyances
mais à les imposer
à leur conférer une aura scientifique ou
noraseptique
en oubliant la leçon de Descartes
qui est que ce n'est pas parce qu'une
croyance nous paraît vrai
qu'elle est vrai
l'esprit critique s'applique d'abord à
nous-mêmes
et quand nous entendrons quelqu'un dire
quelque chose qui nous semblera faux
au lieu de le juger
tâchons de comprendre les raisons qui
font qu'ils pensent ce qu'il pense
je vous remercie
[Musique]